breaking news now at 11 o'clock a child
is dead another hurt after gunshots went
through an apartment wall both children
under 10 years old so this is a live
look right now at that apartment complex
where this happened on Boulder Highway
not too far from Harmon Metro homicide
detectives are providing these details
just a short time ago
the juveniles were inside their house
along with their parents and another
sibling and that there was appears to be
a gunshot that came from a neighboring
apartment that went through the wall and
into their apartment and struck the
juvenile the other juvenile that was
there with the parents appears also have
a gunshot wound to his leg that is not
non-life-threatening emergency
responders took both children to Sunrise
Hospital the second child will be okay
we're told Detective still on scene
actively investigating the situation
there are not any suspects in custody as
of now but we will continue to cover the
story and bring you updates on air and
online